also wie können die Strompreise in
Deutschland wieder sinken wie können wir
die Klimaschutzziele erreichen das sind
wichtige Fragen die die Politik und die
unsere Gesellschaft angehen sollten und
neben dem Ausbau der Erneuerer
Erneuerbaren brauchen wir weitere Form
der Energieerzeugung und wir haben
derzeit in Deutschland noch
funktionierende Kernkraftwerke die über
10 Millionen Haushalte mit Strom
versorgen und deswegen finde ich es
unglaublich dass die Ampelkoalition
plant das im Frühjahr Kernenergie nicht
mehr zum Einsatz kommen soll wir
brauchen die Kernkraftwerke auch
deswegen weil sie eine CO2 neutrale Form
der Energieerzeugung sind und deswegen
mein Plädoyer wir brauchen die
Kernenergie auch über das früher hinaus
wir brauchen Kernenergie aus sozialen
Gründen um die Preise zu senken und wir
brauchen keinen Energie auch damit wir
die Klimaschutzziele erreichen können
wie kam es zu dieser Wende erst den
Atomausstieg beschlossen dann den auch
noch unterstützt jetzt öffnet man sich
traut sich aber glaube ich noch nicht so
ganz vielleicht selbst erneut ich war
selber immer ein Freund der Kernenergie
auch als vor über zehn Jahren in
Deutschland da andere Entscheidung
getroffen wurden genau aber damals hat
man gesagt okay neben Erneuerbaren
setzen wir auf Gas so das war eigentlich
auch zwischen ein Parteien dann
Einigkeit da und jetzt haben wir aber
nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine natürlich eine ganz andere
Situation das ist für die sogenannte
grundleskapazität also wenn es jetzt
hier im Januar wenig Sonne gibt wenig
Wind gibt dann können wir nicht nur auf
erneuerbare setzen deswegen müssen wir
in Deutschland die Frage erklären was
brauchen wir für die Grundlast und da
gibt's jetzt nur noch Kohle oder Kern
Energie und Kohle ist mit die
klimaschädlichste Form der
Energieerzeugung und deswegen sage ich
ganz klar wir brauchen mit einer CDU in
der Regierung hätten wir in 10 Jahren
noch Atomkraft wir haben im Deutschen
Bundestag beantragt dass die Laufzeiten
verl werden erstmal für einige Jahre und
ich glaube persönlich auch dass wir auf
Kernenergie neben Erneuerbaren setzen
müssen weil wir in Deutschland erst mal
wir haben ja einige funktionierende
Kernkraftwerke nein ich bin nein ich bin
erstmal ich bin erstmal für den ersten
Schritt ich bin für den ersten Schritt
nämlich dass die funktionierenden
Kernkraftwerke von denen wir ja einige
in Deutschland noch haben dass die jetzt
nicht alle abgeschaltet werden das würde
uns schon helfen allein die drei
Kernkraftwerke die das laufen können
über 10 Millionen Haushalten weil sie
nämlich wenn man sie weiterlaufen wollen
würde was ich für grundfalt schalte sie
von Grund auf erneuern und Sanieren
müsste das neue bremshebe da rein genau
kein Problem
und damit hat sich dieser
preisvorsetzen hat sich damit auch schon
erledigt und im übrigen es ändert sich
ja nichts an der Tatsache dass
Kernenergie eine brandgefährliche
Energie ist wir hatten mehrere Havarien
die viele Menschen krank gemacht haben
aber eine Mehrheit der deutschen
Landschaften verseucht haben
die Alternative sind regenerative
Energien wenn ihre Partei die nicht über
Jahrzehnte blockiert hätten dann werden
wir schon weiter seine Energie
an der Stromerzeugung waren 67 % der
Strom
viel mehr Potenzial
Deutschland
unterstützenkraftwerke zu Wort kommen
lassen
gegeneinander reden haben wir niemand
mehr dr Frank genau also die gewählten
erfolgsvertreter wie sie ja beide sind
haben wir in der ganzen Sendung jetzt
schon auch gesagt dass sie sich Experten
einladen und Fachleute einladen ich
empfehle Ihnen auch mal Fachleute
einzuladen die in andere Meinung haben
oder halt wirklich Bescheid wissen zum
Beispiel Herrn haferburg ja das ist ein
ein Atomexperte der kennt die Hälfte
aller Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland in
Deutschland der Welt ja er war
Atomphysiker gewesen eben in der DDR und
lassen sich einfach mal von ihm die
Situation erklären lassen warum es sein
kann dass ein deutscher Physiker ja
genialer junge Mann einen fantastischen
Reaktor entwickelt hat in dulflut
Reaktor ja der auf dem Papier
wohlgemerkt es kommt nicht zum Gau er
kann alte Brennstäbe verbrennen wo wird
er jetzt entwickelt in Kanada warum weil
wir in Deutschland uns angewöhnt haben
Problemlösungen nur noch moralistisch
anzugehen ja jemand der eine gute Idee
hat der aber dem narrativ nicht
entspricht von Klima oder Corona oder
was auch immer Einwanderung wird
niedergemacht heute in der Universität
ich habe da viele Beispiele auch von
Patienten die Professoren sind an der
Uni Heidelberg und darüber müssen wir
reden wir haben eine vollkommen
Kompetenz und Sache ja feindliche
Umgebung geschaffen in der öffentliche
Diskussionen das ist unser das ist unser
Problem in dem Sinne glauben wir alles
was Greta sagt nicht doch ein Wahnsinn
und wir haben immer wir haben so tolle
Leute in Deutschland aber sie trauen
sich nicht mehr teilweise die in der
Vorlesung etwas zu sagen weil dann
irgendeiner kommt mit Klima Klimawandel
gibt es aber wenn sie schon begründen
dass mehr Atomkraftwerke brauchen um den
Klimawandel aufzuhalten dann weiß ich
schon das wird nichts ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich für eine Regel Runde hier
vielen herzlichen Dank an meine Gäste
vielen herzlichen Dank auch an sie fürs
zuschauen das war für 8:15 Uhr